well it is no secret that lake mead is
slowly running out of water but what we
haven't heard about is lake las vegas
it's about 30 minute drive from the
strip it's used for recreation and the
site where a lot of luxury homes are
being built the 8 news now i-team has
been learning the lake is currently not
getting filled the i-team's vanessa
murphy has the details from lake las
vegas again located in henderson
aside from the occasional raindrops like
we're seeing today we've learned lake
las vegas is currently getting no new
water that's because lake mead is so low
and this happened sooner than expected
the water for lake las vegas was coming
from basic water company also known as
basic management inc through the city of
henderson as the eight news now i-team
first reported in may basics intake pipe
gathered water at 1050
feet the lake level is now 1040 feet
according to a city of henderson
spokesperson basics intake ceased
operations on july first lake las vegas
was aware of this issue and put
additional water in the lake before that
a city of henderson spokesperson says
lake las vegas and the city are
currently working on a long-term
solution i spoke with a developer for
lake las vegas he says he expects this
to be totally sorted out within two to
three weeks he says the situation with
basics intake pipe happened about two
months sooner than expected but he
insists there's no problem here he says
infrastructure has been put in place to
address the issue and he says it's just
paperwork that needs to be finalized
now the lake needs to be supplied with
water because it evaporates the city of
henderson reports delivering 1.3 billion
gallons of water to the lake from july
to june of 2021 that increased to 1.5
billion this year again because lake las
vegas put extra water in the lake to
make up for the change since lake mead
is so low
now if you've been to lake las vegas you
know there are restaurants here there
are water sports over here you can see
there's some construction again the
developer insists none of this will be
affected reporting at lake las vegas
vanessa murphy live local now